go into the room the voice said
it may seem like a weird room but that's
all right because it is a weird room
don't be afraid the voice said sit down
in the chair drink some water
wait for the hand and take what the hand
gives you
this the voice said is your meat
look at it and be thankful
be thankful because this meat did not
come from an animal
no this meat was grown in a vat
[Music]
[Music]
if this drone was hovering over a
slaughterhouse you would probably turn
away before watching what comes next we
like our tasty burgers we just don't
want to think about what went into
making them medium rare with american
cheese but please hold the misery
this meat factory though is different
it's your friendly neighborhood abattoir
and it belongs to upside foods
meat is fundamentally the most delicious
most desired
food across all cultures and it's a
center of plate for nearly everything
you can imagine people love eating meat
and we want to be able to keep eating
meat for thousands of years coming up
but the challenge we're facing at the
moment is
there's just not enough meat to be able
to produce for a growing population that
wants to get more and more of it
the person in charge of upside is this
fella puma veletti he's not really into
killing floors of death
there's no slaughter here
and we're talking about real meat
not plant-based proteins or meat
alternatives we're growing real meat
using animal cells
but not having to raise and slaughter
animals
[Music]
this is the upside foods production
facility and innovation center what
we're doing at upside foods really is
finding a way to grow real meat directly
from animal cells into the meat we love
if you look around the facility you'll
have small medium large cultivators all
around us they're meant to serve one
single purpose which is to grow real
meat from any animal and be able to grow
that in a matter of 10 to 12 days
put simply upside grows meat in these
vats it takes animal cells feeds them
nutrients waits a couple of weeks and
then digs into the vats and harvests out
some pork chops or chicken breasts if
you look at this place i mean it looks
like a brewery and that's essentially
what it is right right this should be
very familiar to people when you walk to
a brewery you see very large steel tanks
when you walk into a future meat
production facility you should be able
to see very clean tanks that are there
growing meat of any species we love to
eat
these are words that make sense when put
together although the concept itself
takes some getting used to so we'll take
cells from a cow we'll take cells from a
pig or cells from a chicken and we'll
grow them outside the animal and we
provide them with clean and nutritious
ingredients in a clean environment and
we'll let them grow for
a couple of weeks at the end of the
couple of weeks we'll harvest meat which
is essentially the raw meat that you
would get when an animal is slaughtered
and ultimately you cook it just like you
always cooked meat
what's the largest feed of piece of meat
you've ever eaten giant steak 40 ounces
yeah i think i've
probably gotten to the 40.
you had to grow a
2000 pound steer yeah and then cut it
back down to 40 ounces now imagine what
happens in the reverse we're building
that same meat from the building blocks
of cells much faster than what it takes
a you know a beef cattle to grow which
takes two years that's really why the
resource used for cultivated meat is 10
times lower for water use or greenhouse
gas emissions compared to growing an
entire animal for two years and then
cutting it back down to this 40-ounce
steak
upside has raised more than 200 million
dollars from the likes of bill gates
richard branson and food giants like
tyson and cargill they're all betting
that the company will crack the code on
making lots of meat without needing to
do any slaughtering that sound you hear
is pigs and chickens and cows rejoicing
[Music]
uma has graciously allowed me passage
into his meat palace where we shall find
out how upside makes its meat okay so
the feed starts here yep so we're
looking at two tanks this is a smaller
tank and this is the larger tank that is
holding the feed so we're looking at
ingredients that are being mixed in here
in a particular recipe see this little
fan light thing yeah that's a agitator
in there that kind of mixes
slowly mixes so the ingredients are
nicely you know dissolved and that
becomes easier for the cells to absorb
it and the feeds coming more from like a
farm or like a chemical it comes from
agricultural plants you know it could be
corn it could be soy it could be other
plants that people are just processing
to make into powders like flour mills so
we have a milling area where we mill
some of the powders okay so that it can
easily mix into the water then the cells
can start absorbing the nutrients
here we are coming over to the first of
our seed cultivators we have multiple of
them but let's use one as an example so
this is a seed cultivator you grow the
timber of cells into like a flask once
it gets to a reasonable size flask we
have a sterile connection from that
flask into this cultivator okay and
we'll pump the cells in there and then
feed comes in and it starts mixing so
there's literally a chicken pipeline
that's ferrying stuff from one of these
vats to the next yeah and the cells are
naturally programmed to double like i
said every 18 24 36 hours and they're
doubling and doubling and doubling and
doubling and pretty quickly you know in
10 20 30 doublings you're going to get
really highly dense uh cells in here
that become you know let's say if it's
chicken that's chicken growing in there
when you harvest it out it's going to be
like a really dense liquid what you do
then is you separate out the water from
it and it just starts becoming like you
know the the raw meat that you're used
to seeing but it doesn't have um you
know the
the marbling or so when it comes out of
here yeah like what color is it it's
pinkish or it's thinking yeah thank you
because the cells naturally have a
little bit of a pink hue once you take
it out you take it into the formulations
area in the kitchen and you start making
sausages burgers and hot dogs and
nuggets
so that's the step
[Music]
so the these are the big big daddy
cultivators yeah you can say these are
the big daddy cultivators for all cut
meats there's these are the largest of
their kind in the world in any field and
what they do is be able to produce the
textures and the cuts you look from
whole cut meats i get more confused on
the properties like when you cut into a
chicken breast it's kind of like fibrous
and and
i still get a picture in my head how you
guys get the when you start combining
things is it just there's machines that
like
sort of mush this stuff together in
certain recipes and then
there's certainly a role for machines
but the majority of the work that we've
done at upside is actually having the
cells figure out how to make the tissues
between here and actually getting in
front of a consumer it'll get into the
shape of the breast that forming and
shaping of it happens after it from the
solid meter okay and that's just done
with like a machine that shapes that's
the machine but otherwise it's coming
out of this vat more or less okay okay
yeah and we have all kinds of cells we
have uh what we call fibroblasts we have
myoblasts and you know there's other
cells that accumulate a lot of fat
and we're trying to play with the taste
and the textures of each of those cells
when you put into a format of a meat
we're trying to build it from the most
fundamental building blocks
upside started in 2015 and used to go by
the name memphis meats over the years
it's been joined by dozens of startups
also trying to grow meat in big metal
containers uma's big flex is that upside
has moved past the laboratory r d phase
and is well on its way to opening a huge
synthetic meat factory
this building near berkeley california
was just finished and will soon pump out
engineered protein at unprecedented
volumes
what we're targeting is making 50 000
pounds a year okay with the capacity to
go all the way up to almost half a
million pounds like 400 000 pounds plus
but this is basically the one that shows
the world how meat production can be
done from there we use that as a
blueprint to start saying okay now let's
build a production facility that's
purely focused on only production we
don't need to do innovation there that's
the one we start targeting is 10 to 20
million pounds that's our next
production facility that we want to
build okay this is crazy so but like so
if a number of you guys are successful
at this there's gonna be competitions
over just who can make the most
delicious
mate right with their process and and
yeah i i long for that day of saying i'm
actually competing with another company
in the space but
it's gonna be like coke vs pepsi but
with
with like steaks
uma's assortment of meat receptacles and
slurry pipelines was impressive but by
god i'd signed a waiver and given upside
power of attorney over my bowels i
wanted to taste some diy chicken
how many tastings you must have do you
eat this at home with the kids
my kids uh my wife
our dog
we are the first family in the world to
eat cultivated meat
in the in can the dog tell
oh i mean he'll come running towards
yeah right
and then and you guys pick chicken i
would presume because a lot of people
eat it and that this would be the the
biggest early market
that you would have to do chicken or
pork pretty much right chicken is
something that everybody knows how it
tastes it's one of the most desirable
meats in the world and number one in the
world and number one in the u.s so we're
like we're going to put that on the
table i mean that's the funny thing
because whenever you eat some of the
vegetarian stuff it's always like oh
how does this compare to meat and i just
i mean this is just meat
like i mean growing up i grew up eating
you know a lot of meat my dad's a
veterinarian i went to his work and was
always around cattle or sheep
and kind of learned
the you know the love for animals from
that and uh but loved the taste of meat
kept eating it we had chickens in our
backyard
and i had the experience of one day the
chicken i like disappeared and i'm like
where did it go
we just ate it last night and i remember
you know really crying that day it was
hard to process so
yeah here we are i mean
we can have the chicken and eat it too
it's the golden brown yeah expect the
maya the reaction that happening in a
pan
when you're in the room you're starting
to smell the meat oh yeah 100 it smells
like grilled chicken yes
and then as you cut he's cutting against
the bias or the fibers
and you can see that knife is actually
you know you have to work hard to cut it
it just doesn't go through mush it's not
like you're cutting tofu
based on everything i read about you
guys everyone said it actually tastes
like meat so my my expectations are high
okay all right
yeah i mean
this is
that's i mean this is it's meat
i mean it tastes it totally tastes like
grilled chicken that i would make at
home taste is totally there i feel like
the texture is is like
super close a little different is that
it's more tender texture
thinner fibers yeah so
what we've done is different types of
textures we can make thicker fibers but
this one comes in a much more tender
more moist
and thinner fibers so yeah
pretty much delicious yeah
well done
but you otherwise you were going to be a
doctor
i mean for your rest of your life
to the cardiologist for 10 years i think
the calling was always there from as a
child i'm like i really
wanted to be able to be able to
make a meaningful
change or a difference in the world and
i couldn't think of a much better way of
using my skill sets to say if we can use
science and technology we're using to
grow food that could save
you know
billions of humans and trillions of
animals and i felt like
i could continue practicing cardiology
for another 30 years and save two or
three thousand lives but if this works
my gosh like
it just literally would be a giant leap
for humanity and walking away from
cardiology was not easy
and my mom and dad had my mom more than
my dad had a reaction of like you can't
walk away from that like you worked so
hard from it and
you're doing really well
but they also saw from i was little
how much i cared about meat and how it
came to the table and running behind my
dad and playing with all the animals
they immediately got it and my dad was
an incredibly supportive the kindest
person that i've known the only shirt he
would wear for the last five years is
a shirt that i sent and say hey we used
to be called memphis meats and then you
always used to wear that shirt twist of
eight um with kovid my dad uh
has to be last yeah
yeah
my dad was going to be here for the
opening yeah
so that's why it's emotional yeah yeah
no no i understand
well
i mean
it's like about as impressive a thing as
you can
do right to shake up something this
dramatic
upside's technology is admirable and
impressive the company though still
faces a couple of major tests
first the fda has to approve this type
of cell-based meat
and second consumers actually have to
want it when they walk down supermarket
aisles
let's talk about the price for a moment
when you guys started i mean i think we
were 18 000 18 000 for
for how much
for a pound of meat so what has been the
curve down over time so i'd say we've
lowered it by about three orders of
magnitude by about a thousand decks okay
and so that brings us into the territory
of being able to say
we can do premium meat pricing
as we start getting ready for producing
meat at scale you know 10 20 dollars a
plate when you talk about just one one
chicken breast or so or a chicken tender
it's going to be under five dollars this
is a lot of progress in five years um
six five or six years but there is like
a camp of people who think this just
cannot be done economically so we are
standing on a track record of being able
to question the impossible
and keep moving beyond that what i'm
telling uh you know
our own team that's literally broken
nearly every barrier people said we
couldn't do in the last five years right
every single one
that we are talking about today was a
much higher barrier five years ago the
investors are coming in here recognize
that this is a long arc and in order to
create the kind of change we're talking
about this is going to take five years
plus 10 years plus we're set up at a
very interesting moment in history where
the trends of consumers the current
generation are all asking questions
about where's our food coming from and
we want to demand a much better way of
bringing food to the table
the current meat production is 750
billion pounds that's about 70 billion
animals now that demand is approximately
doubling let's say by 2050
we need to have 150 billion animals on
the planet to produce meat enough for
everybody's demands and it's very clear
they are not enough space there's not
enough water and we cannot effort to
have the level of greenhouse gas
emissions and runoffs that come from
that much amount of animals if we are
successful and the field is successful
it's just an enormous opportunity it's
game over for many of the problems we're
talking about
you